today we're going to revisit de moivre's
theorem it's one of the most
useful and interesting and elegant parts
of complex numbers and we looked at it
sort of earlier on
when we were really exploring the
different advantages of polar
and exponential forms for a complex
number but as we're going to have a look
at today i want to show you that you
have to be quite
cautious and careful with damaris
theorem i want to explain the reasons
why
and then i'm going to show you how that
sort of provides the reason
why there's this sort of classic proof
of demolition we haven't looked at
within the course yet and i'm going to
show you how it all works
today so this is a story in three acts
and we're going to begin
with why we need to be cautious
so tomorrow's serum just to ring the
bell for you
is this property that allows us to think
about raising complex numbers
to a power and the way that we sort of
did a very quick demonstration of it
uh within the course earlier was to
think about if you're raising things to
powers
the most sort of obvious place or
direction to go in
is to think about the exponential form
of a complex number because
the exponential form is written with
powers right that's how we get
the argument in there into the index so
if you think about
some complex number that is on
the unit circle so i've got an r a
modulus of
one the sort of uh stock standard way of
stating demarcus theorem
thinks about only complex numbers on the
unit circle and then you can extend it
for other complex numbers
what we do is we say well what happens
when you raise this to the power of
n what insights can we gain well we can
say well look i'm just going to take
this
e to the i theta and i'm just going to
write that e to the i theta so it
can be anywhere on the unit circle theta
can take on any value and i'm just going
to write
to the power of n at the top there but
you can see
that i can immediately write this in
terms of
you know with my index laws i can say
when you raise something
that has an index to it if you raise
that to
another index you raise a power of a
power what you get is the multiplication
of your indices right so i could write
this as e to the power of
i and then i'm going to group together
the n and the theta
of course you can multiply i n and theta
in any
order that you like multiplication is
commutative but the reason why this
particular form is helpful is because
now i can take
the left-hand side of the right-hand
side of the same thing
written in exponential form and then i
can rephrase it in
polar form and out will pop demarvo's
theorem watch me do it
you've got e to the i theta here and so
by definition that is just
cos theta plus i sine
theta and that's apparently raised to
the power of m when you have a look at
this
right hand version here it's e to the i
and then this
n theta that's the argument and so you
have a different
way of writing the same complex number
namely cos of
n theta there's the argument and then i
sine
n theta appears again and this
is de marvelous theorem right it's a
really delightful
elegant result that we've used a bunch
of times to prove things like
some of the the gnarly multiple angle
trigonometric identities that you can
prove with advanced and extension one
techniques but they're just a pain like
you have to
weave your way through these very long
and circuitous
trigonometric identity proofs whereas
here we can just use what we know from
you know comparing real and imaginary
parts we can have a look at
binomial expansions and and using the
binomial coefficients which are so much
more
efficient than doing it the long way
with just the trigonometric identities
so this is great and it's also very
elegant like it took all of like
i think you could call it one two two
and a half lines
to prove this there's just one snag
having a look at this sort of
demonstration of demarva's theorem it
sort of gives the impression when i sort
of did this line here
i did a bit of a sort of secret ninja
move i just said let's raise this to the
power of n
and in the real number system that gives
you no problems raising
things to the power of n doing left hand
side do it on the right hand side no
no big dramas right you always have
equality but
indices in the complex world run a
little bit differently
and that has to do with the fact that
arguments can often take on several
values for the same
complex number and that leads to
problems if we take on particular values
for the n the power that we raise this
complex number to so to illustrate this
to illustrate
that this caution that's kind of not
immediately obvious at all when you look
at this proof of demand
theorem i'm going to take some very
particular values
for n and for theta that are going to
demonstrate why there's an issue here
and why we need to be cautious
so let's take n equals a half what if i
were to
um take this line here demifora's
theorem put n equals a half here and
also put it in
over here as well now to evaluate things
i do need an angle as well i need an
appropriate
theta so i'm going to choose a couple of
different angles and
see what happens here's what i'm let me
zoom out a little bit here's what i'm
going to
give a whirl i want to try for n equals
a half for this particular
power i want to try it for cos
0 plus i sine 0 because that's a
particular complex number
it's going to give me a number on the
eigen diagram and then i'm going to try
and substitute in 2 pi
now you might think that's a bit weird
because you've already done
2 pi 2 pi and 0 are the same that's kind
of the point we should get the same
thing
out of everything here if we just take
um you know 0
on the positive side of the real axis
and rotate
anti-clockwise around 2 pi radians they
should give me the same result
but as you're going to see de moivre's
theorem as stated
runs into a bit of a snag let's have a
go i already did the
left hand side kind of verbally just now
for theta
equals 0 and for n equals a half we're
going to get
cos of 0 plus i sine of 0
and i'm just raising that to the power
of a half okay nothing too dramatic here
inside the brackets there cos 0 is 1.
sine 0
is 0. so what am i getting that's just 1
plus
well no lots of i that's raised to the
power of a half
so that is just 1 to the power of a half
no big deal ok now i know you might be
tempted to evaluate that but
what i can do is i can go to the right
hand side and i can see what happens
over there and that will actually do the
evaluating
for me so i don't need to do any
guesswork about what 1 to the power of a
half is equal to
watch and you'll see what i mean let's
now do the right hand side which which
is here cos
n theta plus i sine n theta i'm going to
put in
n equals a half and theta equals zero
let's give it a go
i get cos of a half times zero
plus i sine of a half times zero again
that's clearly just cos zero plus i sine
zero and uh this looks familiar right
because i
i did this over here so i already know
that this is one plus zero i
this should just give me one and at this
point you are not dramatically surprised
because you're like yeah i thought 1 to
the power of a half
would be equal to 1 because this power
of a half is is kind of like the square
root right and we know the square root
of 1
is 1. but now watch what happens when we
try a different value of theta i'm going
to take the same n n equals a half
and then i'm going to give it a well for
theta equals 2 pi
let's see what happens on the left hand
side here i should just uh
keep i'll keep that pink line of view
there so that i can actually
quite straight into it i'm going to get
cos of 2 pi
plus i sine of 2 pi and that's going to
be raised to
a half still same value of n this is
looking
familiar right you know cos of 2 pi is
still 1
and i sine 2 pi is still 0 i and that's
raised to the power of a half
so you're like what's the big deal right
everything all looks um a hundred
percent fine one power half one of the
power of a half
that's equal to one but now here comes
the kicker
and maybe your wheels have been turning
as i've been doing this working and
you're realizing what problems about to
emerge
what what happens when i actually start
to substitute in
n equals a half theta equals 2 pi into
the right hand side
let's just do the substitution i'm going
to get a half times 2 pi
plus i sine a half
times 2 pi this is going to give me what
half of 2 pi is
pi that's cos of pi there and then i'm
going to have
i sine of pi now
think about the sine function it sort of
starts at the origin it goes up
comes back to the middle um to the axis
at pi so therefore this part over here
this part here
is going to give me uh 0 i just like
before
but not this think about what cos pi is
doing if you were
to picture what the cos graph is doing
that is terribly messy but it's close
enough to say that at pi
cos of pi is going to give me negative
one
negative one plus zero i equals negative
one what just happened
um we have one to the power of a half
that's apparently equal to one
and then we've got one power of half now
equaling
negative one what's the issue here
well we have two distinct values for one
to the power of a half we've got plus
or minus one and what we're colliding
with is the fact that in the real number
system
we only take the principal nth roots
of a number we just say it's just one
just take the positive value
over here um or you know for example if
i i said to you
uh negative 1 to the power of a third
that's the cube root of negative 1 we
would just say oh it's just negative 1
right like that's the thing you multiply
negative 1 times itself
sort of negative 1 times negative 1
times negative 1 that will give you
negative 1. so
that's the only of the roots that we
consider the principal root
not the positive one it's just the one
that makes the most sense within a real
number system
but we can see here that in the complex
number system like that's what's going
on here we're using these complex
numbers
tools the polar form um of a complex
number de moivre's theorem which which
should work right like our proof here
um seems to be watertight but we are
landing on this contradictory issue here
and that's because
in the land of complex numbers the idea
of a principle
nth root makes much less sense like
which of the roots is the principle one
which is the one
that is the most valid the most
important they're kind of all
equally valid they're kind of all
equally important
and so the way like the technical way we
would say this
is that if you have a um a non oopsies
you don't rub that out
if we have a non-integer power that
we're raising our
our numbers to when you have a
non-integer power here
you actually truly get different
potential values at the end
so the technical way of saying this is
that z to the power of n
where z is like a complex we're
considering it as a complex number even
if it's a number like one which is a
real number
um every real number is within the sub
is a subset of the complex numbers it's
just that the imaginary part is
zero z to the n is multi-valued right
you've got one and negative one
or you know when we think about one to
the power of a half you get the cube
roots of unity so
there are multiple values because in
that case ends a third
it's not an integer and that's what this
fancy notation here means
and is not an element of the
set of uh whole numbers the set of
integers
so this is weird right uh and this
causes a problem for denver's theorem
demise's theorem breaks down
when you put in even something as simple
as n equals a half
which is why all the exercises you've
ever dealt with in
that use demand for theorem they always
hand you integer values because that's
kind of where you have to stay
now i said we were going to look and see
why we need to be cautious with
democracy theorem
and here is the sort of essential reason
that um if you pick
non-integer values of n you get this
sort of multi-valued thing happening
here you're like is it one or is it
negative one demolition doesn't
distinguish
between them